welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I'm joined by Harry and Jane who are
both the co-founders of a recruitment
business called trapeze h.r and we just
had to change room really cool
co-working space and near Liverpool
Street and the original room that we had
there was loads of chairs moving around
upstairs we had amazing me so we're in a
better room now and I'm excited to speak
to the both of you and as I was saying
before we started where I always love to
to start and begin this show is how the
both of you entered the lovely world of
recruitment please do share I'll go
first
so I am an HR generalist by my
background I've worked in HR the field
of HR for 25 years Wow and as part of an
HR job a lot of recruitment is done and
I've always enjoyed the recruitment side
of things I've preferred hiring to
firing always and it's it's something
I've feel I sort of thrive in and so
when the opportunity to work more in
recruitment in more recent years and
then set up a recruitment business with
Harriet I was really excited to say you
started in the HR and then went into
agreement to say yeah your perception of
recruitment might have been interesting
from coming from that side and then gone
into a recruitment yeah and I've worked
in lots of different industries doing HR
so I've worked in hospitality and
leisure sectors so sort of hotel
companies and then I moved into
financial services and banking so those
two worlds are very different anyway how
recruitment is done is very different in
those worlds and the type of people
you're recruiting interests very varied
and how did you get into I attempt at
Michael Page years and years ago just as
a PA ok did some traveling and then
actually started as a teacher but
someone I met at Michael Page started
their own equipment business so I was
asked to go and join him when he started
about 15 years ago
and I decided however much love teaching
it wasn't paying enough so I go and join
him so I kind of fell into it and I
actually started there as more of a
support for the other co-founder and
then just really really enjoyed it and
that's that point I knew that it was cut
quite cutthroat because obviously
Michael Page being very big and
international and I was in the City
office you had two high targets and I it
was kind of the periphery of my job I
didn't really get involved but I heard
about it and I saw you know what a good
biller and consultant was was in their
eyes and not so good
but I actually am a relationship space
person so I was never looking at
recruitment like that I was never
looking at it as Billings it was more
around actually I really enjoy meeting
people oh yeah it's actually interesting
and then fell into a cliff which is my
old company and where we live yeah so to
sort of to sort of set the scene then so
the both of you worked in recruitment
for quite a long time yeah 20 years yeah
20 years so then so then both of you met
at a real community accord only yeah
right and you worked only for I would
say Oh in total just over 10 years 10
years and then and then did you then
when internal didn't you said yes I was
there for 8 years I had twins they moved
into easyJet in-house role two and a
half years yeah and then wanted to work
more flexibly so we joined Oakleaf to
start the flexible working desk with
Jane okay cool
and then that led to you then to the
point where you are today which appears
and for you then ginger so then everyone
understand so that that's how you got to
this point and then yourself Jane how
did you get to see starting HR yeah
works of numerous amount of industries
and then you went to recruitment so to
wind back a few years I have a family
and as my young family came along the
world of HR and particularly HR in
Investment Banking wasn't as open minded
to how you could work in a job with sort
of flexible working mind so I happily
worked there flexibly for a number of
years but then when I had another child
and I I wanted to work more flexibly
but banking didn't enable that I thought
right I'm done here I need to continue
my career but I still have my home
commitments so I set up my self as
an HR consultant okay and stayed in
touch with quite a few recruiters in
case some roles came along that I could
do flexibly alongside my consulting and
I wanted to sort of do more in the world
of flexible HR recruitment the seeds
were being sown back then and I
approached oak leaf and and had a chat
with them about how setting up a decks
desks which Harriet and I then did
together could be something that they
should be doing someone should be doing
more about it and they were very
receptive to the idea that's where my
recruitment focus sort of properly came
to go before I was after two and a half
years doing it in June I think for three
no okay and then after that you then
made the decision to start trapeze we
were really enjoying what we were doing
and it became apparent that actually
probably in the part-time kind of
flexible space we didn't have a lot of
competitors and we thought why not go
and do this ourselves and do it our way
all right so just to be clear as well
what you guys and have done sent up
until that point up until now and is
completely dedicated to the flexible and
part-time niche the four and a half
years that Jane was at Oakley from the
two and a half years I went back to we
dedicated to the vegetable market yeah
and that's what you do now right yeah
and then in different sectors or is it
just across sectors SME startups and
some more established businesses yeah
okay cool so before we before we sort of
unpack what what's been going on because
how long is trapeze being going on there
for 15 months
15 months okay before we because I'm
sure you've learned a lot along the way
in that short time I'd be I'd love to
sort of and get some of your
perspectives on and I guess lead them up
to that point because I think the both
of you been on a really interesting
journey right in terms of being internal
it's been an agency for nearly well over
a decade right and yourself gone from HR
background etc so I guess just to help
me understand the people listening the
both of you then have you had
experiencing managing teams building
their etcetera is that tip what you did
over that time in the agency world or
was it not was that more yourself or no
I didn't ever choose to manage a team
really I think the opportunity wasn't
there when I was first to Oakleaf
because we were still growing
and then when I came back I selfishly
wanted to work flexibly and therefore I
don't think that comes hand-in-hand with
managing team so the both we've always
focused on billing for your own
recruitment desk but in your own
relationships and building your own desk
individually okay
that's interest in and okay then so why
don't be then because I think it will be
really useful when we start talking
about trapeze is there let's focus on
and the time whether both of you were
building up that particular market that
both of you so probably the most common
thing I get asked around is and Hisham
my my biggest challenge or what I'd love
to get advice around through the people
that come on the show is and people
building death people building clown
relationships and and business
development ultimately so I guess what's
been your experience with that and how
have you typically folk focused and and
executed that in your career because I
think we were yeah if it was PSL clients
okay that that wasn't something we built
up we were if you like lucky in inverted
commas to get a client that we already
had it oak leaf that then thought we
might look at the flexible market so
trapeze is the area where we actually
have built up a death okay that's
interesting so why don't in stead then
why don't we talk about because that may
sound easy but I'm sure there's still an
element of work tactic strategic element
to expand an encounter several actually
we're kind of been doing this for you
you have how open would you be for us to
doing this for you etcetera right or not
well I think one of the reasons we've
done what we've gone and done and said
trapeze up is because we felt quite
constrained by the environment that we
were in is fair enough we were in a big
recruitment consultants Eve Airy well
known highly thought of but there were
parameters around what we were able to
do or we had scope to do or budget to do
and the freedom to do it in a different
way on our own meant we could talk to
anyone we wanted to we could break down
the doors and go and talk to private
equity clients venture capitalist new
new growing business sectors that to be
frank a lot of the recruiters out there
aren't I haven't even scratched the
surface of and so that was what was
never negatively but just
way of wicked already system
relationship so they a decision made
where you could try and speak to them or
whatever and I know whether it was we
couldn't it's just our day-to-day job
didn't lead it to that today and now
we've got the freedom to speak to who we
want when we want okay
yeah if that's the case because I think
a lot of people get a lot of value out
of that so how have you gone about
building the client Bank over the last
fifteen months so inevitably our network
has come into play and that's been built
up over the years that Jane's had an HR
and I've had him HR equipment and
in-house I think part of that and this
is where I you know if I may be so bold
to say my strength is in building
relationships so I'm at the time you
know I might have had a job 10 years ago
that I filled but I always filled it
with the best of my ability and really
got to know those candidates and now
we're seeing those candidates come back
as clients and and as always one does
you follow your recruiter so you might
they might work for a recruitment man
but you don't go to a recruitment firm
because of that firm you go because
you've got a great person they're sure
ordinarily so that's how we've built
some of our business up and I think
we've recognized that with two people
we've got different strengths
capabilities skill sets and Harriet's
recruitment sort of expertise in my sort
of HR brain and the fact that I've
worked in different sectors and we've
got some pretty extensive networks
between us and then we've very sort of
openly gone to and and met with and
marketed our proposition to and they've
been very receptive to it and even if
they haven't been able to help us with
giving us a new sort of head of HR role
they've probably known someone who can
yeah so it's really
yeah and I think there's something to be
said for doing a job well so we take a
really consultative approach with
clients a lot of our plants from the
startup space or SMEs who could have you
know even two hundred people and still
haven't had any HR presence at all um so
quite often it's let's go in and have an
exploratory chat about what HR actually
does and obviously people have an idea
but they don't really understand the
strategic element or they're kind of
this is how your business can really
thrive with someone in the people space
um so a lot of it is groundwork we put
in even some of them of twelve months
ago thirteen months ago and we just
actually yesterday a client we met
months ago has come back with an
opportunity for us so we put the
groundwork in and this is what it looks
like and a lot of these entrepreneurs
are very young so they haven't actually
even worked in probably more than one
other business so it's that consultative
this is what we can do for you this is
what HR can do for you and then we leave
it with them and a lot of what we've
found we end up doing as Harriet just
said is educating our clients about what
HR can do and what an experienced three
day a week HR person can add in terms of
value to your business because people
just think of process and procedure but
there's a whole gamut of other things
employee engagement culture you name it
change pieces that that HR can do which
some some business owners have no no
concept of what HR can do it helps also
that our backgrounds are I've been in
house but Jane's an HR specialist so we
actually know our market really well in
terms of what HR can offer and the types
of people out there and I guess what
were you were touching on there which i
think is really interested in have you
always had a long-term mindset and
approached building relations that way
did you get on because I think that's
where a lot in today's day and age right
if I don't get something now and then in
the first three months this relationship
then it's a lot easier then for that
relationship to fall off the cliff for
it then it's not coming - well actually
no we did yeah did you get why I mean
have you always like how it's really now
I think I'm just like that as a person
invested in people if I go out no one
has dinner parties anymore meet someone
I'm actually genuinely as my friends say
quite nosy and annoying because I like
the detail but I'm really interested in
their lives and I think that transports
into work as well I think that's just
how I am and Jane you are as an
individual
so yes I've never thought of it as
longer term relationships I actually
really enjoy getting to know my
intuitively I like getting to know
people and the candidates all clients
I'm speaking to now someone phoned up
yesterday and I helped her in her first
HR job 10 years ago you know she's
remembered me which is amazing and
actually have to be cycling mber
everyone because they get married they
you know we will change and we go
through a lot in 10 years but I love the
fact that they've obviously remembered
me if you don't come back just to break
that down because clearly you've done
that quite intuitively which I think
it's amazing but someone listening right
now who may not be quite naturally good
at that and yeah what would would your
advice be to someone because you're
clearly intentionally or naturally
leaving a mark on that person or really
going above and beyond for that person
which means they will come back in 10
years like what would you say the core
key things that people can actively
consciously do to hopefully help that
happen will start building that Ritz to
get my min yeah I so first of all I
think there's two types of recruiters
they're probably many others but in my
view there are two one who wants to make
a lot of money and move on fast or just
make a lot of money and the other that
wants to make money but actually um and
it doesn't mean to say the first type
doesn't care but actually really cares
about what they do and I think if it
doesn't come naturally to you but you do
want to do a brilliant job and you're in
it for the long term then you just
really have to think about who you're
speaking to how you speak to them and
and care so that means going back with
feedback if they're not right for
something taking the time of day and we
can't get back to everyone obviously and
nor can Jane and I so you have to pick
and choose but as long as you put
yourself in that person's shoes and
think I'm a job seeker at some stage in
my life so this is how I'd like to be
treated
I'm a client and I want to make sure
that the recruitment consultancy is
representing my brand and me properly
then actually that goes some way into
building relationship in a trusting
relationship do the right thing there
are some words we're very very values
driven
I've got a business and and I think
words like integrity and passion are
over utilized and and not understood at
all so we don't use them about ourselves
although I know I've got passion for
what I do and I've got buckets of
integrity as as Harriet but I think what
we're trying to do is bring back a very
human element
into the recruitment experience for our
clients be they candidates all the
employer of the the job that we're
hoping to fill for them and just
flipping everything on its head and and
being down-to-earth honest with people
the hardest calls to make are two
candidates who you really wished had got
the job but you have to deliver some
pretty blunt feedback we package it as
best we can but we're really sorry the
reason you didn't you weren't successful
and how many cruises don't call them you
want them to learn from that we did have
one candidate you just get kept getting
knocked back because um she came across
as really aggressive and actually that's
feedback I found myself of how I talk to
people sure at home and at work
and I really wanted to give her that
feedback because she's had it from for
jobs and she's got brilliant CV and
excellent experience but at that and
that's not something she can SLO change
but she needed to be aware of it rule so
we had to package it I'm sorry we had to
give it to her we couldn't package it up
as you know oh it's something else we
had to say your CV is brilliant you've
got the experience but you were coming
across this way and that's thankful yeah
and I think time back into what you send
there in that person coming back to you
I think it's those difficult
conversations that feel willing to have
now that person will be grateful for a
year's time two years time you'll be
remembered we do small things to sort of
remind our candidates placed candidates
get a gift from us when they start in
their new job it's not it's just a well
done we're so pleased that we've found
you a great opportunity that enables you
to work in the way you wanted to work
flexibly etc and as a nice little so
little touches little human touch that
the bigger bigger companies probably
can't do we're small and we never plan
to be too big we have vision and you
know that's that's the type of
experience in and create and yeah I have
a point of difference right I mean it's
so saturated reputation is key for us we
want to be remembered for being having
given people a really positive engaging
experience that's down-to-earth
straightforward and and just says it how
it is in his own yeah in again in front
of makers practical as possible for you
who are listening when you said around
that
who came back recently and you actually
had a meeting with them a while back how
how do you then structure that sort of
process or structure in your daily
weekly plan to make sure that that does
happen if that makes sense you get on in
terms of cultivating these relations
that long term one set visits
development leverage Network how does
that typically form then in a typical
day in your world so we feel quite
strongly about adding value to what are
sort of what we do as recruiters that
and it's not just about selling and the
idea of them hiring through us so all
the little value add things we have some
sort of thought leadership events that
we host and trying to get people to come
and have a roundtable discussion about
well yesterday we had one on mental
health okay and got a group of really
well-informed senior HR people business
owners entrepreneurs talking around a
table for an hour over breakfast around
what what can we do to make a real
difference and that doesn't cost us very
much money it costs people time and
people made some good connections in the
room and we've heard that people have
having lunch and coffee together next
week we met in the room so we're adding
value to that day for those people and
we'll do another event in that chair and
our network isn't it yeah and so value
value add initiatives that are so you've
also implemented and strategically
obviously because you're paying forward
and you want to put these people
together and you're trying to actually
make a positive difference which is what
you're about but also then I guess for
let's say crime X that you spoke to two
a months ago in between that you can
actually contact a person and say well
we actually have an event by the way so
you've created other sort of touch
points there yeah and when we we end up
connecting quite a few clients outside
our events anyway because they might say
and it's maybe easier never tacoma's in
the startup world because they need
quite a lot of help in some areas and
inspirational ideas so it's it's you
know easy to say well have you met John
Smith because actually he does this
connect it that way and also our coach
clubs been really great and that's why
we set that up we have amazing HRM
interims on our
talent pool but a lot of them are
coaches which is why they want to do
flexible working in HR and we were like
we've got all these people who are so
talented in coaching why can't we offer
the coaches more clients but also offer
our clients some coaching availability
so you know that's not that's not an
initiative that's gonna make us lose
money but it's initiative that's going
to help our clients and also help our
coaching pool know I felt that's really
smart and I guess the events piece
that's actually come out quite a lot
over the last four set of eight is quite
common right yeah yeah have you always
done that like since starting this or
when he was at previous in the previous
company we didn't really do a lot of it
Oakley because um because it was I guess
a business wide thing not just a lot
more people there we've done it here but
we've been able to pick the topics that
are close to clients hearts so next
month we have one on culture and we've
got a particular class how have you
decided on the points there well because
we've got a particular client on that
one who wants to asked us around how do
you think I get more of this in my
culture or how do I grow my culture
we've had another client happened to be
kind of told that she needs to hire 40
percent females in her senior population
so how does she do that so we had one
around diversity and kind of that's
again direct help for that individual
was hopefully more people will come with
their thoughts on that and how they do
things but it's also topic of the moment
mm-hmm so providing solutions to the
problems that our clients face is
exactly how we feel we can add intrinsic
value to what they're doing day to day
aside from the fact that they might hire
an HR person you know where we've given
them a solution by gathering together a
clever group of people who've all got
opinions all got stuff they've done well
differently and they can add that to the
pot after an hour sitting around a table
we all come away with that was a really
good idea that John mentioned about what
he's doing about culture in his tech
startup so that's a key thing for and
has it made you more money doing the
events we haven't been doing them long
enough to know that but what we do know
is that and respect isn't quite the
right word but I think we're valued and
we're seen as valued members of their
network I'm next Wednesday night we're
going to see containers house I hope
you'd have a nice glass of wine with a
client that we worked with over a year
be firm who have got a massive event and
they're a private equity firm who have
loads of portfolio businesses within
their reach and they've invited us and I
actually did email back and say you sure
we're on the list this year because we
work we came last because we were
working they said absolutely we'd love
you there and I believe we've kept in
touch to them and in throughout the year
and not for anything other than we've
been relationship with them so we want
to keep that and we've asked them if
they want to come to our events we've
offered our coaching which is actually
if the next couple of months kind of a
free taster session and we and when we
did work with them we really really
spent time going into the nitty-gritty
of what they were looking for what HR
car do and that sort of thing and
actually we've never placed with them
they've got an interim in which they
found through their own network but they
want us to hire when she leaves at the
Christmas so um you know those are the
sorts of things that we're really valued
for I think and just by the fact we've
been asked back shows that yeah no I
think the reason why I asked that is
because at the end of the day typical
recruiter listening right it's like yeah
these events sound great a lot of people
do them but like how is it gonna get my
recruitment ask you I mean we were
marketing something absolutely then it's
a long-term game and it's not again but
you're looking for the future you're not
working for the now and they're not
totally and I think as well if you and I
think that's got to be the mindset when
you do do initiatives like this you go I
mean if you're going in with a simple
mindset of right how is this gonna
affect my Billings this year there's a
very high chance that you may make a
decision on that basis that you may not
get the best people in the room or do
you get what I mean and I think that
that's the way you should approach it
and you know I did say to Jane this week
or last week we've worked for days and I
haven't done what I would call any
recruitment and Jane said but this is
BTS OBD and it absolutely is but it's
hard to see when you look at your bottom
line thinking whatever bought in this
quarter yeah when you're not actually
working on roles for the now so we've
got a few roles on now but we obviously
haven't got as many as we'd like because
everyone would know but actually all the
things that we're doing all the
initiatives are doing are paving the way
for the potential pipeline and if
they're not next month they might be
next you know months after that so okay
that's pretty interesting so have the
both of you always so you did a bit of
consultancy before mm-hmm
have the both of you always wanted to
have your own business never even
thought I would do it really
I forced into doing it because my
options were limited to work to continue
in my HR capacity continue with my
career and quite ambitious about it and
juggle home priorities so I was slightly
forced into becoming a consultant
enjoyed it and it gave me loads of flex
yeah but it's much more fun doing it
with someone else
really so why would you so thing come
back just now in this short 15 months
like who would you go back and do
anything differently yeah lots of things
different and I do believe and you hear
all the time from people who start
businesses we've learnt from them I
would say they've paid a strong people
say but we've learned and it's made us
more cautious in other areas mmm what
would you say is what when I say when
you think about that was the sort of
thing that comes to mind in good ways
and bad ways we tried to mirror what we
knew so that was a system in place quite
quickly
well we hardly use our system and we've
paid a lot for you have some like weird
black notebook that you know but we
should save us money and that's been one
I think also just being aware that we
aren't a big businesses established so
things are going to be different and
with the highs and lows of recruitment
anyway you just kind of have to be aware
of that but I I can honestly say that
I've changed as a person I never thought
I would do business I didn't have a lot
of confidence around this sort of thing
um because I guess until you try you
don't know how you could you're going to
be and I don't know failing yeah no one
does really like yeah but I also and I
don't know if it's an age or a stage of
life got to the stage where I'm like
I've got quite a few more years to work
but I've already I'm 42 is I've got some
years under my belt
and if I'm going to do it this is the
time yeah cuz I guess there's a lot of
people if you were sitting in a other
name anywhere maybe some friends similar
areas there blonde won't got why no how
would you do that they say it's quite I
feel like be quite easy to just say that
to you and I would you do that no just
stay working you're employed I knew I
wanted to leave my last business and
actually Jane um mitigated the risk by
saying if it doesn't work out you can
get another job and I and I'm I'm not
cocky but I know that I'm good at what I
do and I care so
feel good at what you do and you have a
passion for it then you will get another
job mmm and I don't know I think that's
a great question to wash yourself isn't
it love what is the worst that could
happen yeah and if it all goes then
we'll find another job but it's it's
going really well
and it's it's fun and work is fun ya
[Laughter]
know I really think that's good for me I
think person that has that's got to be
the objective isn't it I think
especially in recruit Minik it is a very
unforgiving job so like if you even when
you're doing well you're not that happy
or that pleased you go I'm in since you
did mention the the highs and lows there
I guess you said you've changed as a
person and these types of things I'd
love to understand a bit more about have
you had to cultivate more resilience
have you had to have different
conversations with your family because
you have to work but other night so my
resilience has always been something I
found difficult and that's been picked
up in my career in the past and I take
everything to heart and I wear my heart
my sleeve um but I think growing I've
grown as a person because I've learnt to
take things on the on the cheek or
whatever the expression and move on and
actually I've kind of enjoyed seeing
myself grow which sounds really weird I
don't quite like airy-fairy but I have
the conversations with family friends
yeah my husband's constantly saying
you're working every evening bla bla bla
and I and I do and I don't like it and
we've promised ourselves that we won't
do it after a certain time of evening
and we've got commitments elsewhere
either with family or you know plazas or
whatever it might be so we don't sit at
our desk and work but equally that means
that if we want to leave at 4:30 to go
and pick our kids up from club early or
whatever then we can do that because we
know we can always log on for an hour in
the evening but my resilience has
definitely changed angry how have you
cultivate that then like I have it like
you said you said airy-fairy well I
think what we talk is self-awareness
right you noticed that
well actually the resilience is
something I did always have to work on
that someone now I've really had to
swallow and get better at so have you
other
included something in your daily habits
or have you done anything that has
cultivated that all has it literally
been well it's really little things and
this is going to sound bizarre to people
who don't know me but lady on the train
drops melissa the other day and i would
ordinarily have got really annoyed with
that and it there and thought to my mind
why is she dropping it if everyone
dropped better this train will be
covered in litter i said to her as I got
off the train would you like me to pick
that up for you and pop it in the bin
she don't know no others in a minute and
she may well have been doing it but she
dropped it and kind of hidden it under
her chair now it sounds ridiculous but
for me I was like oh my god yeah so that
it's all those little things are making
me grow in confidence and that's not a
resilience in the workplace example but
it what it means is I know that I can do
things and they don't have to become out
in the wrong way or that I can have the
confidence to follow through with things
and if they're not well received she
could have told me to F off yeah yeah
but I was prepared for that because I
thought I've got to try it
I've got to try and the same in work we
have to try things if they don't work
out the coach prob might not work
something another initiative might not
work but unless you try you're not going
to know I think the openness that we
have as cofounders of a business with
one another has grown immensely in the
last 15 months we knew each other pretty
well to start with we are good friends
we've got lots in common we're also very
different but we're coming up.this from
the same perspective of how we want to
run the business or how we want the
business to be positioned and we have a
very open line of communication we don't
hold any grudges we bicker we spat we
fall out like sisters and we it's done
move on no time for baggage and which in
a bigger organization where you might
fall out with them on that desk because
you don't agree with his approach with
the client that we're working on
together we just say it to each other
and we're it's done move on we're
passionate about things yeah has it been
like that from day one or have you had
to whatever you had to implement like I
don't know you know I mean we haven't I
don't think we have we it just been like
that natural there and how much does it
help the both of you that you're doing
it together do you think yeah I couldn't
I wouldn't want to do this with anyone
else really I couldn't do it on my own
and so it's
why is that do you think like what what
what's so unique and powerful and
special about dinner of another person
equipment can be quite lonely as we all
know and you can work really hard and
something doesn't pull off equally you
can not do much work on something and it
comes off and you're like wow so I think
especially if you're running your own
business you'll never sure where them
next money's coming from if you're
complied by someone you know you've got
a base salary so you almost know what
you're gonna be doing month for month so
that's that's a you know big pressure
for anyone whether you've got family or
not and you can bounce ideas off someone
you can get a sense check I think our
yin and yang of complementary skills as
we've mentioned sort of earlier is is
quite unique in a recruitment sense
because it's quite unusual to have an
in-house recruiter who's got a lot of
agency experience paired with someone
who's this not subject matter expert but
has worked in the field you're
recruiting into so when we line up in
front of a client that's pretty
compelling and what we then say because
we know we're good at what we do is
makes it even more compelling and so we
know we're good
without sounding arrogant now we know
we've got substance and we'll be honest
with people and we'll tell them straight
and no no I think a lot of CI me
recently start my own business it's on
my own I think what what's also great
about that is the accountability piece
as well right so you send that and
sometimes wouldn't work later for that
well it's not just on your shoulder it's
actually someone else it's set of
announce right which I'm sure can only
help the drive and the decision making
and these types of things right we could
have an idea this afternoon and start
doing that is the cool thing don't have
to get it sanctioned by some height we
might chat to the husband's or in a
couple months time when it you've been
going for two months yeah yeah but it's
that freedom to make decisions and to
say that I'm not happy with that that's
working you tweak that so I'd really
like to dive into the flexible working
piece because I think it's such a and
don't say buzzword but it's so easily
used instead these days but before we do
that I'd love to get your point because
you just touching it there in terms of
internal experience your agency
experiences cetera et cetera like what
what's your approach now and I guess
what I'm trying to think about is people
listening and even when I was a concern
on agency sidelight there's always that
sort of friction between internal
recruiters and agency right so like I
guess people listening who do come up
against that who have always got that
constant balance of should go to that ly
manager but internal recruiters not to
and we've got a relationship I don't
obviously damaged that etc like what's
been your sort of hallway experience
from being internal to agency in what
have you learnt that has enabled you to
make sure that you get the internal the
internal regret did you get what I mean
what what would you think about that so
I have always someone let's say played
by the book will be a bit boring but
even if I know the hiring manager really
well
I would always then loop back in the
recruit or the HR person internally
because there's absolutely no point
bypassing them because at some stage you
will come up against them as your main
client yeah in the near future or even
at that company so again that's about
the relationship piece in the respect so
as I was just saying what I'd love to
get your thoughts on being when you was
an internal recruit or when an internal
like what do you think are the common
mistakes recruiters make in terms of
damaging that relationship because I'm
sure you did experience things you've
been inside you always wasn't mindful of
and playing by the book or whatever but
then go an internal like what would the
common the flipside said the other side
is when I was internal and we use
agencies which wasn't that March they
would go straight to lying to say but I
know James really well and I he's told
me to send TVs and I'll say but that we
have a process and that's the thing
everyone has a process whether you're an
agency or in-house you have a price list
to follow so if someone's bypassing that
process then there's no trail you know
there's actually no fairness in a sense
because other candidates haven't been
able to get a look in so I guess it's
it's about giving everyone an
opportunity so I don't think it works to
play the short game and try and get in
there but the common mistake would be
well actually no no Harry
because I'm great in yeah and then all
of a sudden the internal players have
probably got that back up a bit then
because you've sort of set the line and
as you said not respected their process
which is their process yes and quite
often that role might not materialize to
anything because you know you've got
people to get sign-off with it
everything else if they've gone in
because James thinks that he's got a job
but he hasn't actually gone through the
proper routes
you might end up doing all the work as
an agent we can actually not have
anything done so I just think it's
always even if James is asked to work
and you then loop in the recruiter and
say just so you know and that's a
conversation for the internal recruiter
in the client to have not before them
necessary to have with you and from an
when I was on this sort of HR side of
things and that happened regularly the
recruiter would go straight to the line
manager in the bank I was working in and
say well I went to school with Jeremy I
want some movies directly to Jeremy no
like well Jeremy's admin is not very
good you will lose your CVS we will have
no trail of what's gone where and to be
frank if you upset me on this then we'll
just list you and we won't you know as a
recruiter and you then tell your boss
that that's happened respect isn't it
House recruiter I think it is I think
it's you said I'm not show respect the
process is their process it's there so
it's just just to wrap that up then like
if I'm a recruiter right now listening
and I'm just really struggling to get
this internal or the internal team HR
whatever on my side what's like the
goatee to try and get these people on
your side to meet them first of all
really meeting I think if you're on a
large PSL list like preferred spy list
and they can't meet every agency then
you know there is always that problem
because they don't want to spend their
days meeting agency but you've got a
differentiate yourself into grow
relationship you either need to meet
them we'll spend time talking to them on
the phone and getting to understand how
they work and telling them a little bit
about how you work on why you're
different to the next person okay and
and how or how you would like the
recruiter to behave differently how can
we be different to may be asking
questions yeah that's really and try and
find a hook that's going to
differentiate you against others but I
think ultimately have a long-term
mindset double down on the relationship
respect the process
and just keep at it and I think then
it's about hoping that will lead to some
sort of window of opportunity where then
you've got to put your money where your
mouth is and actually be what you said
that you're going to be and you get why
I'm in yeah that sort of makes sense
okay so flexible working then the reason
why I say it's really really common than
these types of things is so what I do
with people that I work with and when we
one of the things that we do is and
really think about their target audience
before we get them creating an in
content right so I would say one of the
most common challenges for different
sectors that I've worked with their
candidate that they're trying to attract
and engage with online is flexible
working and more and more candidates
that they deal with and speak to want
flexible working more and more important
to them etcetera etcetera why do you
think that is in a nightlife as a whole
that people are searching for flex for
working hmm because life is so busy so
there's two different types of people if
you ask me they're the guys coming up
the Millennials which I can never say
who don't just want one job now they
want to be able to have some side
projects or will do a little bit of
portfolio business area which is what we
see all those people at certain stage of
life you actually think I've worked
really hard five days a week and as we
grew up as kind of eight to six or
whatever it might be and I want to do
something different so they might have
elder care responsibilities in mind
childcare they might want to do yoga
might just actually want to spend their
day off riding we've got quite a few
candidates who do exercise in the day
off and my book some of them so I think
life is now entwine so much with work
and home life is not two separate things
and people actually see it is if I can
get a bit of flexibility in my job
doesn't necessarily mean part-time but
it can mean agile working then it'll
enable me to do other things
mm-hmm and would you say that typically
again in quite broad but that could
typically enable people to be have a bit
more happiness in their life and did you
not I mean absolutely and also um with
technology nowadays as we all know
there's not a new thing you can work
from anywhere so if you've got a long
commute or even if you haven't you could
save that money or time on commute and
maybe go for a run in the morning or
actually just have a coffee quietly in
your house or whatever it might be but
you're not always having to run out the
door or something so you gain two hours
back ten
yes how realistic is this in recruitment
if you look you only need to look around
to see that to try and be attractive to
potential recruiters agencies they're
offering all kinds of things
unlimited holiday flexibility one boom
no core hours so I do think it's
realistic when I was in my old business
in the early days I do see a lot of
clock-watching from my manager and from
me he would be waiting for 6 o'clock
until I could leave and I'd be waiting
till 6 o'clock because I'd done all my
stuff and I was ready to go um you know
I was the highest bidder on some of
those occasions but I'd done my work and
I was ready to go so I don't think the
hours you work necessarily you take to
how good and successful you are I think
if you're sensible and you want to do a
good job then that is irrespective of
the hours and when we talk to clients
today yesterday tomorrow where we go in
and see them we encourage clients not to
think about hours and days output
interesting what do you want this person
to achieve in in a day or in a week and
and the project that needs to be
completed and and you have to judge
people on their performance and missed
my HR brain kicking in as well not about
whether someone did nine to six five
days a week because they could have been
doing nothing in those hours more very
ineffectual work or very unprofitable
worm the business but if you judge
people on what they produce and deliver
and how they come across to clients in
those meetings and because they're
happier because they've got a slightly
shorter day today because they get to go
home and walk their dog or yeah nice
really I really like the way that you
put that and I guess how what would you
say is the typical sort of challenge or
pushback a typical business owner would
give you or give me if I'm saying I'd
love the opportunity to have a bit more
flex but like would what is do you think
as a typical challenge for a business
owner that's sort of holding them back
from going I'm not sure I want them to
be at the desk all day like I'm not did
you know I mean what's a typical step
their preconceived ideas or how they you
had to work and it's a generational
thing the guys and girls that we speak
to who are in these new-age businesses
terrify growth startups private equity
backed
new world sectors they they everyone
there expects to work flexibly it's
not-it's not since the standard the more
traditional financial service banking
legal accountancy where everyone always
works Monday to Friday in our
organization it's it's a little bit more
of an alien concept they're missing out
on talent that's our biggest thing there
is a massive talent pool which is one of
the main reasons we started this
there's a massive talent pool of
candidates who want to work differently
women men all ages all shapes or sizes
who want to work differently but because
they're not offered opportunities
missing out yeah yeah absolutely love
that and I I can I couldn't agree more
that just thinking back to so I'm
regretting an insurance sector and yeah
as soon as someone says to you I can
only four days a week stress like I
can't do it from that person then no and
it's so true you get put into the too
difficult to help box yeah totally
and I was that candidate when I was
leaving the bank when I decided to go to
consultancy from because I just sort of
oh hi Jane sort of consultant on the
phone talking to Jane Middleton who's a
candidate we like her she seems quite
decent quality as an HR person the
minute I said really looking for three
days we haven't had a three day job on
four years and this was ten years ago
changed immeasurably and in our time
just doing trapeze it's it's come on and
the dial is shifting yeah and these new
businesses that are promoting it that
it's not unusual to be enabled to work
more flexibly that's great that's
pushing the darling what I'd love to get
your own perspective of and I guess
advice for people listening like if I'm
listening right now and I I've done
recruitment for a while and I'm more
than capable of yeah being responsible
for working at home or whatever it is
because I'm comfortable manage my diary
and whatever right how can I approach
that subject with a recruit like how
would you go about approaching that
recruitment business owner go and let
you know I feel like you can trust me
they're like how can I start proposing
flexible working they attract a good
track record in terms of Billings and
you know being a being there so rather
than absent helps obviously because if
someone is underperforming and you know
trusting and actually Oakley for me was
a prime example I'd been there for a few
years before I had kids I work four days
a week and that's just because I wanted
to work four days a week I wanted a day
at home had a long commute that I wanted
to just do stuff on so I had a
conversation and I talked about the fact
that actually I would be better in terms
of how I worked and smarter in my work
if they could give me a trial with Ford
a week um and obviously we had to talk a
little bit more detail about how it
would work who covers my work on the day
off how that might work of someone place
the job I got but actually it worked
really well and I did it for a whole
year and then I actually fell pregnant
so I left any way but you know I guess
it's start we've actually let's be
honest with let's be honest with
yourself
have you bred trust with the person that
employs you oh yeah like you can't just
do it because it's like cool and it's
what I want to do is it's something that
you really thought about and actually or
someone that when they'll go into that
office and ask it they're gonna go okay
that's fair enough because you're
someone that
yeah yeah and you don't you know it's
the same whole thing don't bring me a
problem bring me solution so I had a
solution there on my day off this is how
it would work so you know if someone
else is going to do my work then they'd
get a spit at that or whatever so it
wasn't God wasn't gonna have to pick up
your work on your day off they're not
going to be happy with that so
effectively they wanted me to be as good
as I had been I needed to actually have
a day off a week now so to be able to
perform that's what I needed but to
enable someone to cover my work so the
business weren't losing out that's what
they I could give them mmm that's really
interested in so okay yeah cuz I'm just
trying to think like I guess it's a
mixture of first and foremost you know
make sure you build some real trust and
they trust you and then it's like
actually put a bit of a business case
together and actually think about it
strategically and smart if it's
something you really want and I guess
there's a real element then as well as
light is it actually something that you
want do you know I mean cuz I think it
could be like for my friend who's
recruiter eyes it works four days a week
like that sounds great in the face of it
but what how did you actually structure
it dead like how does it actually work
is that something that would work for me
but guess there would be an element as
you just said there a trial period
because you don't know until you try it
obviously but if you do try and your
work at home just like oh my god I hate
it like I need to be run your office
blah blah blah but you don't know until
you try our guess right and if there's a
recruiter out there
wanting to work more flexibly than a why
haven't they contacted trapeze HR and be
maybe think about other people in your
organization I'm thinking female in
particular if there's people in your
organization who are at your stage of
life who are challenged with childcare
issues I mean you can afford to drop to
three days have a conversation put
yourselves together as a job share and
proposition your business owner and say
could we share a job and we'll come up
with some commission structure and a
finger it comes back to that question
what's the worst that could happen right
exactly and if you're miserable and
you're gonna leave anywhere least try
the known trusted root of your employer
that's paying your salary currently yeah
and it could be win-win you kill the
client relationships you get that
continuity everyone gets continuity
known colleagues because I think that's
that you touch an interesting point
there so and a while back I did a sort
of women in recruitment week and sort of
what came out of that came out that
which is was really interesting is
obviously there's it's always
conversation I think it's across my sets
is why there's less obviously female
CEOs and lots of things right and I
think a real big part of that is that
obviously as a guy there's I don't get
to a point where I'm pregnant and I've
got make the decision where it's like
okay so I've worked my absolute sort of
stuff to get to the point where I'm in
my career but now I've got this sort of
really weird decision where I've got a
bit okay am I'm gonna start a family or
I'm gonna and they and then in the types
of organizations that I work in it's
it's actually evil raw it's not well
actually you can you can do both and
we're gonna do it would that be fair to
say I think that's a real impact on why
there isn't a lot of females that at the
top of the food chain or whatever
because they've had to make that
decision yes yes mental and what I think
again we talked earlier about our job is
pioneers or ambassadors of the flexing
flex working movement nature I had a
complete mind blow and our education and
awareness moving side of what we do
which again some larger recruitment
owners would probably think I don't want
my recruiters going in talking to
clients and sort of
Consulting to them I want them getting
jobs on where the jobs well part of our
work is almost like a social purpose
element whereas if we if we can educate
some business owners to recruit
differently and think about if you hire
Janet three days a week to run your HR
platform and she's going to cost you 50
grand for the three days she used to
earn 120 in her old job she doesn't need
to earn that anymore but what you're
going to get in the clout the experience
that credentials the senior management
capability is you can't buy that and if
you paid 50 grand for a five day a week
person you'd get a much different level
you've gotten to the point where I went
in to ask you about to solve and
finalise this again thinking about
people listening and the conversations
they're having because these recruiters
now will be constantly be getting the
question always they're flexible working
these types of things so then what I
just trying to send the flip so that you
sort of touched on there is if I'm a
recruit right now and I've really
started to notice that candidates are
now working for four years ago didn't
say flexible working was important how
can I now approach that with a client
that I've got to go I'm in so I think is
it coming from the education piece and
the creature goes to client it says I've
got some brilliant five-day-a-week
candidates but I'd love you to look at
this four day per they are really really
high quality I'd say they're probably as
good if not better than the five day
people please consider so is it again
thinking of if I'm if I'm a recruit
listen I'm going right okay so there are
definitely a bank of people in my market
right now that only want three days and
four days but my client hasn't told me
that they're opens flexible working but
everyone tell them they want it is it
then yeah making sure thirty that these
people actually good secondly obviously
M actually crying a bit of a business
case and making sure that that business
case is solving a real problem and
talking about sort of the way that you
just spoken about there were actually
this person can and achieve this for
your business it on less time and she
did cross this but you should cross that
so we're actually really put together a
really good business case particularly
if you're in a environment where you're
struggling to find the client then why
not suggest someone
yeah and you're then being a creative
imaginative entrepreneurial recruiter
yeah and someone who isn't great is just
gonna go yes client I can do that yes
probably consultative yeah that's really
interesting so that yeah okay that's
really cool conscious of time I think
that's really valuable to talk about
that and I think a lot of people will
get a lot of value out that because it's
just becoming so so so important so get
just just to finish off them before I am
asked what the both of you were excited
about on these types of things like how
do you see this planning out in terms of
this whole flexible working thing and
the next sort of five to ten years or so
you guys are banking on it quite a bit
in the four years but even if I look
back when I wanted to work for X B 10
years ago so my kids are eight but as I
said I started working for four days a
week before that um it's already changed
technologies enable you to work wherever
you want to work and however you want to
work so actually being present in the
office isn't so key there are some jobs
and HR is one of them where you have to
see your client group and get to know
them and build that trust so obviously
there's that I need that face-to-face
time element but I think it's only going
to go stronger look at the world around
you look at the startups look at the
SMEs look at the new generation coming
through they don't expect to be in an
office base the whole time look at this
office we're in a co-working space you
know people flit and come to and from
their traveling all around the world so
I'm flexible and agile working and we're
careful to put them both together part
time used to be what we talked about in
our old business but flexible and agile
is now because three or four days a week
since that days I work part time
whereas agile is you can work for how we
want to in terms of the hours so it
could be 90 degree or 10 - it could be
from home so there's that kind of agile
workforce where some offices grow so big
they don't have a physical office space
for everyone so there's kind of that a
jalopy asking and sometimes you work
from a home base while you work
somewhere else um and then flexible
working we've got a role on which is
five days a week but there's two days
from home one day you can kind of decide
around so I think the whole piece is
more seen as a flexible as a part as
opposed to this is straight part-time
and also there's a part time to look a
bit like the old traditional eighths
touched it isn't it yeah and I've been
called that before when I was when I was
in the house why are you or the
part-time person off you go prove it's
already it's a bit apologetic as well
it's our time I'm working part of the
time yes so it's not very intelligent
language around what someone's doing a
cracking job for you they're just not
working the full width so true because
if you say to me I am on part-time
recruits are you're not a serious agree
then that's what our clients used to say
to us well if they're part-time with
English goes damn it yeah we blow my god
no they've just got other things in life
that they also want so they can do this
for part of the week but most you know
most of them are still as good if not
better because they've got less time
they're smarter at how they work thing
that I've noticed in no time we've been
building our part sort of brand with
trapeze is people have stopped
apologizing for wanting to work part
time
don't apologise don't say I only want to
work three days I want to work don't
give it a descriptive adjective or
whatever only is and sort of try and
apologize the language is really
important so important and flex it flex
working is here to stay
Millennials Gen Z Gen Y whatever they're
called I don't mean that flippantly but
I can't remember hey Gen Z coming out of
uni going to their first job or going
from school to first job they don't
expect to have to write a formal written
request for flexible working they
imagine to go into a tech firm and be
told we don't all work here all week we
work a bit from home if you prefer to
work in the office come in but you don't
have to we just want you to perform at
your best and do your best job and be
happy enjoy working here so it's it's
outdated to think that you can't show me
a job that can't be done work flexibly I
think that's the way we should think so
before I ask you the final question what
are the bow for you excited about what's
going on in the trapeze world excited
about where it's going to go next yeah
as Jane said we can come up with an idea
and try it and if it doesn't work you
know time and a look a bit of money as
potentially
otherwise that's that's my mantra to
myself try it try it appease if it
doesn't work yes it'll be sad and
disappointing but you can find something
else try the coach club see how it works
you know so I'm excited to see how we
can push ourselves as individuals and as
a business we're obviously looking to
hire so that's really exciting we're
looking to expand we don't want to be
vast we want to keep our values and to
do that I think you need to remain it
kind of rethink tenets and candidates so
we live and breathe that I think the
scale of the opportunity for trapeese
whilst we're in a quite specific sort of
world in terms of those clients that
might want to hire an HR person flexibly
if they're only 30 employees large
themself they're not going to need a
team of five in HR but where this could
go how how many great recruiters could
come and join us over the coming years
and we could expand our reach who knows
into other worlds outside HR and provide
clever solutions to businesses that that
need a more creative mindset from their
recruiting I think it's amazing what
you're both doing I really like and I do
generally mean that nothing is a job the
last question I always ask people is if
the both of you could communicate every
single recruits are out there they'd
listen they take on your advice it could
be a word a phrase what comes to mind be
human be human on technically good no am
I gonna say mines care but care doesn't
seem like a strong enough word but I
think it's respect for what you do these
these are people's careers so you know
all all jobs someone might not want a
career they might just want a really
good job and they've got something to
give so you have to think of both sides
the candidate who's been looking for a
job for a while who might not be right
for everything but feed that back and
the client who actually just wants a
really really good person to join their
team who gets a culture and could do a
job well amazing I like it well Harriet
Jones been a pleasure - thank you thank
you